we are learning new details about the
alleged murder of an Italian police
officer by two American teenagers police
say Finnegan Leigh elder and Gabriel
Christian Natalie worth had been
drinking and at least one of them had
taken drugs before their encounter with
the officer Seth Doane joins us from
outside police headquarters in Rome Seth
what else did investigators reveal good
morning Anthony one of the first things
to come up in this press conference with
the Carabinieri today was discussion of
that photo which you recall of Natali
orth being blindfolded during
questioning that kind of an Yeti
criticized that they said it had only
been that teenager not elder who was
blindfolded it was only for a brief time
and they clarified they had opened an
investigation the teenage suspects were
visited by US embassy officials Monday
Finnegan Lee elder and Gabriel Christian
Natali yourth remained locked in a Rome
prison facing charges of murder and
extortion new judicial documents which
extend their detention provide context
of the events of late last week and
revealed the teenagers had been drinking
alcohol and that the judge finds they
have a total absence of self-control and
critical capacity and demonstrated an
excessive immaturity surveillance video
shown by Italian media though not
independently confirmed purports to show
the teenagers who were trying to buy
about ninety dollars worth of cocaine
which turned out to be aspirin then
fleeing with a bag they stole after the
drug deal was busted I saw them running
away said this eyewitness to plain
clothes officers from the Carabinieri
force were called including Mario
Churchill Arreaga who elder admits to
stabbing claiming it was self-defense
because he was being strangled the
window's documents the judge notes there
were no signs of strangulation and the
multiple stabs are not legitimate
defense the teens also claimed they did
not realize they were fighting with
police but Judge Kiera gallo said that
was impossible as the police had shown
their badges
Natalia yourthe claimed during
questioning he did not know about the
stabbing until after they returned to
their hotel room where he
the teens have contradictory accounts as
to who hid the murder weapon in their
room a knife police say elder brought
from the u.s. one of the other things
that we learned today is that police say
that they were attacked immediately by
the two American teenagers we also
learned that the officer who was killed
did not have his gun but Michelle police
clarified that he would not have had
time to use it anyway start only details
set down in Rome thank you